Peter anybody hey how you doing hi hi we
are here in the office there aren't
really many people here this guy yeah
this guy r2d2 but what we also have is
this Star Wars loot crate we're gonna
see what is inside this because you know
it's kind of been a very Star Wars II
week all right I'm hoping for a
lightsaber a bb-8 viola medic Laurens in
a Georgia mask oh man you are hitting so
many levels
Wow no no we got to do the review okay
okay all right
including Falcon another Falcon also
here's here's the limited edition crate
look at that let's let's go through
these hot damn
first up you got a Star Wars beanie with
some 80 80s imperial logo on the top
there I love it a lot we don't even know
if this is ours or it's actually just a
walls or fences yeah we have no idea
what I'm stealing these alright Peter
one you pick one out here uh so we got a
Darth Vader collectors edition pop
taters which sounds like a potato made
out of Darth Vader but I'm actually
going to assume it's a mr. Potato on the
side we got here a it's definitely a
scarf rebel Imperial scarf so this this
seems to be very ot themed at the moment
cool that goes very nicely with the
beanie in my opinion Vader and I'm back
over here J pingback can't wait to get
on the bus and flash my new Rebel
Alliance team fanny pack that one
BAM Red Bull I look sick
ah yeah you know it's got kind of cool
interior set r2d2 and other stuff in it
after that we got a t-shirt mmm now here
it looks like a v8 on the first Force
awakens you notice that go for this
looks like the first force awakens
memorabilia right here this shirt
actually looks pretty good
I like it there yeah I like it a lot you
like the color blue dude I just got it
cd8 I do that's pretty great we've also
got a loot crate exclusive issue of Star
Wars Vader down I don't know what that
is I'm assuming Vader takes a spill or
something yeah great
sorry what for app and for all you
crafty them people out there we got the
metal earth 3d metal model kit of kylo
Ren's command shuttle no blue or subtle
required dude I don't know if I could
I'll read to you rob because we just got
a little golden book library for Star
Wars it's a collection of six books for
children that go back to the prequels
and all the way through the original
trilogy and up shoot like the force
awakens the representation force awakens
here plumber
well whatevs you got bb-8 yet kylo who
knows when this takes place yeah so if
you haven't had enough Star Wars already
you could have I guess gotten in on this
limited edition from loot crate Star
Wars box and maybe have a few leftover
loot crate calm you can sign up to do
things like this we're not advertising
for them we are just sharing the love
because it's pretty cool company that
sends out neat stuff so for all your
loops and crates and all that good Star
Wars stuff stay tuned Gamescom
you